ahí quiero saludar a todos los pueblos
del mundo que valoran la paz y la unidad
entre las naciones distintas iguales Les
deseo la paz a todos
Quiero
agradecer que estemos unidos en la lucha
por recuperar la paz y por garantizar la
paz para todos los países que sean
Víctimas de una agresión Armada se ha
cometido un delito contra Ucrania y
pedimos un castigo justo el crimen se ha
cometido contra nuestras fronteras
estatales se ha cometido contra la vida
de nuestro pueblo El crimen se ha
cometido también contra la dignidad de
nuestras mujeres y de Nuestros hombres
el crimen se ha cometido contra los
valores que les convierten a ustedes y a
no mismo también en la comunidad de
Naciones
Ucrania pide un castigo porque se
intente robar nuestro territorio castigo
por el asesinato de miles de personas
castigo por tortura y por la humillación
de mujeres y hombres castigo por la
turbulencia catastrófica que Rusia ha
provocado con su guerra ilegal y no lo
ha causado solo para nosotros los
ucranianos sino que es una turbulencia
catastrófica que ha causado para todo el
mundo para cada una de las Naciones
representadas aquí en este salón de la
asamblea general de Naciones Unidas
intervengo En nombre del estado que se
ve obligado a defenderse a sí mismo pero
que además cuenta con la fórmula para la
paz deseo Hablar a todo aquel que quiera
Escuchar Como lograr la paz voy a
presentar una fórmula que puede
funcionar No solo para nosotros sino
para todo aquel que se encuentre en
circunstancias parecidas a las nuestras
se trata de una fórmula que castiga el
delito que protege la vida que recupera
la seguridad y la integridad territorial
que garantiza la seguridad y que ofrece
determinación
es 5 condiciones vemos para la paz
distinguido presidente de la asamblea
general distinguido secretario general
de las Naciones Unidas jefes de estado y
de gobierno
distinguidos periodistas naciones del
mundo
Ucrania quiere la paz
Europa quiere la paz el mundo quiere Paz
y ya hemos visto Quién es el único que
quiere guerra
solamente hay una entidad entre todos
los estados miembros de Naciones Unidas
que ahora si pudiera interrumpir mi
discurso diría que se alegra de esta
guerra de su guerra pero no vamos a
permitir que esta entidad impere sobre
nosotros aunque sea el estado más grande
del mundo
Ucrania está demostrando fuerza en el
campo de batalla ha recurrido a su
derecho a la legítima defensa de
conformidad con el artículo 51 de la
carta y nadie podrá reprocharnos ahora o
en el futuro que somos débiles o que no
podemos defendernos que no podemos
luchar por nuestra independencia
estamos obteniendo resultados en esta
lucha y vemos cómo va a ser el fin de
esta guerra y ya vemos también Cuál será
la garantía de una paz estable la carta
habla de la igualdad de las naciones
y hemos demostrado que Ucrania es igual
entre los iguales la carta protege la
inviolabilidad de las fronteras y
Confirmamos nuestra frontera Estatal
echando a los ocupantes la carta de las
Naciones Unidas estipula el valor de los
derechos humanos de la dignidad de la
vida y nosotros lo hacemos también con
cada ciudad ucraniana que liberamos de
la ocupación rusa nosotros no provocamos
esta guerra
celebramos 88 rondas de conversación en
distintos formatos para prevenir esta
guerra desde el principio de mi
presidencia hasta el día 24 de febrero
del año en curso pero Rusia en lugar de
detener el crimen de agresión que ya
empezó en 2014 lo convirtió en una
invasión a gran escala y no nos quedó
otra que defendernos nos estamos
defendiendo y empujamos al agresor Allen
de la frontera reconocida
internacionalmente del estado de Ucrania
y este es precisamente el primer punto
de nuestra fórmula para la paz un punto
completo el castigo castigo por el
crimen de agresión castigo por la
violación de las fronteras y de la
integridad territorial un castigo que
tiene que producirse
mientras que las fronteras no se hayan
recuperado hasta que no se haya detenido
la agresión
y hasta que no se hayan compensado los
daños y las pérdidas que ha causado esta
guerra
por tanto las sanciones contra el
agresor forman parte de la fórmula de
paz bloquear el comercio y las
relaciones con el agresor forman parte
de la Fórmula por la paz todo ello ya
forma parte del castigo Mientras que el
agresor forme parte de las toma de la
toma de decisiones en las organizaciones
internacionales
no podremos avanzar tendrá que aislarse
habrá que aislarlo mientras que dure la
agresión hay que rechazar el derecho al
voto hay que quitarle los derechos a la
delegación
retirarle el derecho al veto cuando se
trata de un miembro del Consejo de
Seguridad de las Naciones Unidas hay que
castigar al agresor también en las
instituciones
tampoco podemos
ignorar a los propagandistas que
justifican la agresión sino que tenemos
que aplicar un paquete completo de
restricciones personales también Este es
un castigo por mentir los ciudadanos del
Estado agresor no pueden ir de turismo
de compras en el territorio de aquellos
que valoran la paz sino que hay que
alentarles a través de las restricciones
a la emisión de visados de luchar contra
la agresión en su propio estado hay que
castigar por alimentar el mal
se necesita un tribunal especial para
castigar a Rusia por el crimen de
agresión contra nuestro estado
esta sería una señal para todos los
agresores futuros de que tienen que
defender La Paz o si no se les exigieran
cuentas
hemos preparado una serie de pasos
concretos para la creación de este
tribunal y estos pasos los presentaremos
a todos los estados Ucrania pedirá a la
asamblea general de Naciones Unidas que
apoyen un mecanismo internacional de
compensación y Esperamos contar con su
apoyo Rusia tiene que pagar por esta
guerra con sus activos ese también es un
castigo es uno de los castigos más
terribles para los altos cargos rusos
que valoran el dinero por encima de
cualquier otra cosa
el segundo elemento de la fórmula de paz
es la protección de la vida Eso es lo
más concreto
ahora que continúan las reuniones de la
asamblea general en la ciudad ucraniana
de islam en la región de harkif siguen
las exhumaciones
cuerpos que se encuentran en una fosa
común
una fosa común que se creó cuando el
territorio estaba bajo control de las
tropas rusas Ahí están los cuerpos de
hombres de mujeres de niños adultos
civiles y soldados
445 tumbas
una familia murió bajo los escombros de
su casa después de un ataque aéreo ruso
el padre la madre niñas de 6 y 8 años
los abuelos
un hombre que fue ahorcado con una soga
una mujer con huesos rotos y heridas en
todo su cuerpo un hombre castrado Antes
de que lo asesinaran y Estos no son los
primeros casos
así que por favor
habrá que preguntarles a los
representantes de Rusia porque los
militares rusos están tan obsesionados
con la castración que se les ha hecho a
ellos para que ellos quieran hacer esto
a otros
lo único que diferencia la fosa común de
lo que el mundo vio en bucha es de hecho
el tipo de fosa
el ejército ruso estuvo en isum más
tiempo
y por lo tanto
los cadáveres fueron enterrados y no
estaban distribuidos por las calles
Cómo podemos permitir que el ejército
ruso permanezca en territorio ucraniano
cuando sabemos que están cometiendo
estos asesinatos en masa en todos los
lugares no podemos tenemos que proteger
la vida el mundo tiene que proteger la
vida cada estado que sufra una agresión
Armada necesita la oportunidad de
proteger sus ciudadanos y deliberar su
territorio
si necesita ayuda con armas o bombas Hay
que darles esta ayuda
si necesitan ayuda financiera para ello
Hay que darles ayuda financiera si para
lograr esto es necesario ofrecer datos
de inteligencia háganlo pero lo que no
se necesita son mentiras
nosotros podremos volver a izar la
bandera ucraniana en todo el territorio
lo podremos hacer con la fuerza de las
armas pero necesitamos tiempo hemos
intentado acelerarlo hemos intentado
aplicar las disposiciones básicas de la
carta de Naciones Unidas para Ucrania a
través de las negociaciones pero Rusia
le teme a las negociaciones reales y no
quiere cumplir con una obligación
internacional justa le miente a todo el
mundo lo típico que hacen los agresores
que hacen los terroristas incluso Ahora
cuando Rusia habla de nego lo único que
quiere es
ralentizar su retirada Rusia Quiere
pasar el invierno en el territorio
ocupado de Ucrania y preparar las
fuerzas para lanzar una nueva ofensiva
nuevos duchas nuevos y zooms O al menos
quiere preparar fortalezas en territorio
ocupado y realizar una movilización
militar en su país no podemos aceptar
una guerra aplazada Porque será todavía
peor que la guerra que estamos viviendo
ahora para nosotros esta es una guerra
por la vida y por eso necesitamos apoyo
a la defensa necesitamos armas equipos
militares bombas
necesitamos armas ofensivas
necesitamos largo alcance eso es
importante para liberar nuestro país si
necesitamos sistemas de defensa sobre
todo de defensa aérea y necesitamos
apoyo financiero para mantener la
estabilidad interna y para cumplir con
las obligaciones sociales con nuestro
pueblo la protección social y física son
dos elementos de cualquier vida en la
nación Así que el segundo elemento de
nuestra fórmula esta protección de la
vida con todo lo que tengamos todo lo
que permita la carta de la estaciones
unidas
el tercer elemento de nuestra fórmula
para la paz Es que se restablezcan la
seguridad y la integridad territorial
vean Cuántos elementos de la seguridad
internacional ha socavado Rusia con su
guerra la seguridad marítima la
seguridad alimentaria la seguridad
radiológica la seguridad energética y la
seguridad frente a las armas destrucción
en masa ya estamos restableciendo la
seguridad marítima en la seguridad
alimentaria y doy las gracias al señor
Antonio Gutiérrez por
su participación personal
Argelia Etiopía Egipto Libia Kenia
somalia Sudán túnez
bangladesh Israel India Irán yemen
chipre china Corea el Líbano Turquía
Bélgica Bulgaria Grecia Irlanda España
Italia Países Bajos Alemania rumania y
Francia
todos ellos ya han recibido productos
agrícolas ucranianos y tenemos que
aumentar este suministro por mar
tanto dentro de las condiciones de
Mercado y en el marco del programa
mundial
de alimentos de las Naciones Unidas del
cual Ucrania siempre es un asociado
confiable y por cierto pese a todas las
dificultades generadas por la guerra
decidimos
proporcionar existencia humanitaria a
Etiopía y a somalia Así que les
enviaremos una cantidad adicional de
trigo pero es más difícil hacerlo con
otros elementos de seguridad
en vísperas de la reunión de la asamblea
general Rusia disparó misiles
contra la central eléctrica nuclear de
Ucrania meridional la explosión
afectó a los edificios de la central
estallaron los cristales de las ventanas
quedaron dañadas las paredes los cohetes
explotaron a solo 300 metros de los
muros que protegen a los reactores Y
esto es después de que loewe hiciera un
llamado claro a Rusia para que frenar a
cualquier actividad hostil contra
instalaciones nucleares en Ucrania y en
particular contra la central eléctrica
nuclear desde polilla que es la mayor de
Europa y que Rusia ha convertido en un
objetivo Y eso hace que todos ustedes
sean objetivos
el chantaje que hace Rusia con la
radiación es algo que debería
preocuparles a todos y cada uno de
ustedes porque ninguno de ustedes
encontrará una vacuna contra las
enfermedades causadas por radiaciones el
la crisis del costo de la vida continúan
decenas de países está arraigada en la
desestabilización del mercado energético
es necesario retirar el factor principal
de la turbulencia mundial de los precios
a saber el chantaje que hace Rusia con
la energía es necesario topar los
precios a los cuales Rusia exporta sus
recursos energéticos hay que hacer que
el cas y el petróleo de Rusia vuelvan a
ser simplemente
mercancías ordinarias actualmente el
petróleo y el gas son las armas
energéticas de Rusia y por eso manipula
los mercados para que la electricidad el
gas el petróleo
y el diesel se convierta en el
privilegio de unos pocos en lugar de ser
un bien común disponible para todos
limitar los precios equivale a proteger
al mundo Esta es la manera de
restablecer la seguridad energética la
seguridad de los precios pero lo hará
caso el mundo o tendrá miedo de hacerlo
tendrá miedo de las amenazas de Rusia Es
necesario dar solo un firme paso tras lo
cual todo quedará claro
ya ha llegado el momento
ese paso pondrá todo en su lugar después
del terror causado por Rusia con los
misiles después de las masacres después
de mariupol después de la quema de
presos ucranianoska por el ejército ruso
después de bloquear los puertos después
de los ataques de los tanques y misiles
de Rusia contra centrales eléctricas
nucleares y después de las amenazas de
utilizar armas nucleares algo que se ha
convertido en la regla no en la
excepción para los propagandistas rusos
finalmente hemos de reconocer a Rusia
como estado patrocinador del terrorismo
a todos los niveles en todos los países
que confiesen y profesen los valores de
la paz y la protección de la vida humana
a nivel jurídico y a nivel político sino
tienen ustedes un mecanismo jurídico
pueden tomar una decisión política en
los parlamentos Esta es la base para
restablecer la seguridad internacional
si se da este firme paso se disiparán
las dudas las dudas de si tomar otras
medidas importantes y lo que es muy
importante es la frontera la integridad
territorial cuando un país trata de
robarle el territorio a otro estado
está atacando a todas las naciones del
mundo la seguridad internacional no se
puede restablecer Si no se restablece la
integridad territorial de la nación que
ha sufrido la agresión armada por tanto
el tercer elemento de la fórmula de
Ucrania para la paz consiste en el
restablecimiento de la seguridad y de la
integridad territorial el cuarto
elemento son las garantías de seguridad
toda nación tiene el derecho a garantías
de seguridad no solo las naciones más
grandes no solo las más afortunadas
tenemos propuestas para modernizar la
estructura de seguridad de Ucrania y de
Europa y del mundo
que no permitirán que se vuelvan a
agredirnos ya estamos presentando esas
propuestas a nuestros asociados se trata
de propuestas de tratados bilaterales y
multilaterales jurídicamente vinculantes
son estas las condiciones para que
actúen los garantes y el calendario para
que sus intervenciones
arrojen resultados resultados en tierra
mar y aire resultados en la diplomacia y
en la política resultados en la economía
y en las finanzas resultados en el
suministro de armas y de inteligencia
cada uno de ustedes recibirán el texto
de nuestra fórmula para la paz y también
verán Cuáles son los pormenores de lo
que nosotros ofrecemos como garantías de
seguridad no quiero
comparar nuestras ofertas con las
garantías de cualquier alianza que
exista ahora en el planeta quisiera yo
recalcar que es siempre mucho mejor
garantizar la seguridad de una nación
con carácter preventivo
que tener que frenar una guerra una vez
que ya hayas tallado
y el quinto elemento de la fórmula de
paz de Ucrania es la determinación algo
sin lo cual los otros cuatro elementos
no funcionarán
se trata de nuestra determinación de
luchar la determinación de los asociados
a ayudarnos y también ayudarse a sí
mismos y se trata de la determinación
del mundo a unirse en torno Al que está
combatiendo la agresión armada y de
llamar al orden a quien amenaza a todos
por tanto los cinco elementos de nuestra
fórmula serían castigo ante la agresión
protección de la vida restablecimiento
de la seguridad y de la integridad
territorial garantías de seguridad y
determinación de defenderse a uno mismo
Esta es la fórmula de Crimen y Castigo
algo que ya conoce muy bien Rusia y esta
es la fórmula de justicia
y derecho y orden
que Rusia todavía tiene que aprender
como cualquier otro posible agresor que
es lo que no está en nuestra fórmula la
neutralidad
quienes hablan de neutralidad cuando se
están atacando la paz y los valores
humanos en realidad quieren decir otra
cosa hablan de indiferencia
cada uno para sí mismo eso es lo que
dicen pretenden interesarse en los
problemas de cada quien
se ocupan de cada quien oficialmente
empatizan pero solo por protocolo y
por eso
pretenden estar protegiendo a alguien
pero en realidad solo están protegiendo
sus propios intereses estos es lo que
genera las condiciones para la guerra y
esto es lo que hay que subsanar si se
quieren crear las condiciones de paz lo
único que ustedes necesitan es
determinación
mucho se habló de reformar las Naciones
Unidas y en qué paro en nada si se fijan
ustedes de manera detenida nuestra
fórmula para la paz verán que su
aplicación ya se está convirtiendo en
una reforma de facto de las Naciones
Unidas nuestra fórmula Es Universal y
une a los países del norte y del Sur
hace un llamado a la mayoría del mundo y
alienta a que se amplíe la
representación de
aquellos que todavía no tienen voz esto
es un desequilibrio cuando África
América Latina la mayoría de Asia en
Europa central y oriental
cumplen con el derecho de veto el que él
ellos mismos nunca tuvieron y de esto es
lo que está hablando Ucrania han oído
ustedes alguna vez a Rusia pronunciar
estas palabras y aún así es miembro
permanente del Consejo de Seguridad por
algún motivo
Y entonces
por qué motivo no lo son Japón o Brasil
Turquía o la India Alemania Ucrania
el día en que así sea es cuando se
resolverá esta cuestión en cuanto a las
conversaciones entre Ucrania y Rusia
probablemente habrán oído ustedes
a Rusia decir otra cosa sobre las
conversaciones como Si estuvieran
dispuestos para negociar pero hablan de
las conversaciones mientras que anuncian
la movilización militar hablan de las
conversaciones pero anuncian pseudo
referendos en los territorios ocupados
Entonces
qué es lo cierto la movilización militar
en Rusia es lo cierto los referendos
fraudulentos también son cierto Rusia
quiere la guerra es cierto pero Rusia no
podrá frenar el curso de la historia la
humanidad y el derecho internacional son
más fuertes que un solo estado
terrorista Rusia se verá obligada a
poner fin hasta guerra la guerra Que
ella misma ha empezado
descartó que la solución se pueda lograr
sobre otra bases distinta de la fórmula
de Ucrania para la paz
Cuanto más lejos llegue el terror
infligido por Rusia menos probable será
que nadie en el mundo
acepte sentarse
a la misma mesa con Rusia y sí mis
palabras van seguidas de más misiles y
actos de terrorismo de Rusia
lo único que hará es demostrar su
debilidad la debilidad de Rusia su
incapacidad de prevalecer sobre nuestros
incapacidad de prevalecer sobre el mundo
lo único que demostrará es que los cinco
elementos de la fórmula de Ucrania para
la paz se deben llevar a la práctica lo
antes posible estamos dispuestos estamos
listos para la paz pero para una paz
verdadera franca y justa por eso el
mundo está de nuestra parte y por último
quisiera dar las gracias a los 101
países que votaron para que se pudiera
proyectar mi discurso pregrabado fue un
voto no solo sobre el formato sino sobre
los principios Solo siete países votaron
en contra vela Rush Cuba Corea del norte
eritrea Nicaragua Rusia y Siria 7
7 que tienen miedo del discurso
pregrabado 7 que responden a los
principios
pulsando el botón rojo
solo 7 101
contra 7 amigos si esta coalición está
en contra de nuestra determinación
Entonces los felicito a todos porque
esto significa que la paz prevalecerá
sobre cualquier agresión
y que no hay nada que nos impida poner
en práctica la fórmula de paz Muchas
gracias por su atención una vez más les
deseo a todos Paz esclava trading Gloria
Ucrania